with thousands of doses of the vaccine
now arriving in our state we need
lots of people to administer them so in
today's health watch
hundreds of dentists across the state
are ready to give the cobia vaccine
when and if the governor calls them in
for emergency help
now state and county agencies have been
fine-tuning a distribution plan for many
weeks now
and it's likely that dentists would be
pressed into service
once we're ready for mass distribution
so that could be probably weeks months
away
they would volunteer as part of the
workforce
you would go to a hub let's say the
thomas and mac
unlv school of medicine wherever it
might be to give out these vaccines as
part of a whole army of people
correct yeah we've already got dentists
across the state that have been reaching
out to
the health and human services department
trying to sign up to help volunteer
um but again we can't quite do that yet
to it
and dentists in general we like to help
we want to make a change in people's
lives so
i mean i would see people actually you
know closing
their office for a day or two just to go
and help administer it just
he went on to say that having
pharmacists and dentists give these
vaccines
would free up our front line health care
workers so they can
care for those who are infected and
being treated for the virus now if the
emergency declaration happens
dentists would help out for 120 days